hello everyone and welcome to another
incredible game from Round 4 of this
year's Norway chess you guys requested
it as it features a queen sacrifice most
likely and also because the players um
involved with this game are gookish and
the Magnus Carlsen so it's an Armageddon
game their classical game ended in a
draw was a a pretty uh fighting draw uh
some 80 moves I believe and maybe even
88 moves uh it was a queen and pawn end
game in the end there was really nothing
for the entire game like it was a 0.00
uh not um not uh a lot of chances for
either of them so it had to be decided
in Armageddon so gookish gets uh 10
minutes magnets get seven minutes but
Lucas needs a win uh to actually win the
encounter so let's see what happened
here uh gookish with the white pieces
opens with E4 we have E5 by Magnus
Knight F3 Knight to C6 and Bishop to C4
the Italian game is on the board and now
Knight to F6 the two nice defense and
now not uh of course Knight to G5 which
I'm sure Magnus would very happily meet
with black instead D3 this is the main
line the uh the modern Bishop's opening
uh with Bishop to C5 and now Pawn to C3
we have Pawn to D6 transposing into the
main line of the Joko pianissimo and the
bishop to G5 with H6 Bishop to H4 and
pawn to A6 with Knight B to D2 and
Magnus just goes um uh Bishop back to A7
with castles Queen to E7 uh and now
point to B4 is not messing around
he wants to get a for B5 in uh and G5 is
the move that usually is played here but
Magnus plays castles here and it is now
as of move 10 then we have a completely
new game so bookish of course continues
pushing on the queen Side Pawn to a four
Magnus goes Bishop to E6 offers a trade
of Bishops uh but uh would very happily
trade this because then he gets the
Knight to C4 then the Knight can come to
E3 then the Knight can come to D5 or F5
and he will have an excellent attacking
potential uh here we have Rook D1 nicely
developing and just Bishop captures and
C4 we have Knight captures and now Pawn
to B5 Magnus opens up the a file eight
characters a captures and not Knights
the A5 gulkish now wants the a file for
himself and Magnus says all right let's
do it Knight captures on A5 probably
expecting B captures on A5 uh but okay
Lucas would get a pass Pawn this way but
then Magnus will play c5b4 and Magnus
would also create a pass B Pawn so
bookish instead plays a rook captures on
A5 with Bishop to B6 attacking The Rook
sacrificing the B5 Pawn uh and Google
goes for it Rook capture some B5 so now
he wins the pawn but he lost the a file
uh which Magnus will now be able to use
and here Magnus goes Pawn to G5 attacks
the bishop here Bishop to G3 and now
Knights the D7 re-maneuvering and also
maybe even considering moves like F5 uh
so you know you you will have to be very
careful because you will get to attack
but you will also weaken your king side
a bit too much maybe so Google says all
right Pawn to D4 we have F6 by Magnus
and now D captures an E5 F captures on
E5 and now Pawn to C4 uh just uh
grabbing more space on the queen Side
Pawn to C6 uh this way uh The Rook can
be trapped and of course bookish knows
this but uh he is up upon and he wants
uh to make use of the open King's
position so he will sacrifice The
Exchange uh C6 Rook captures some B6
Knight captures and pawn to C5 now and
if Magnus captures it would be just
terrible for him for example if he
captures Knight captures an E5 can be
played H4 can be played uh his entire
Center is ruined and the King side is
wide open so you know in
um in Armageddon with little time on the
clock I do not see him surviving this so
instead he just plays Knights to D7 and
now C captures on D6 we have Queen to E6
uh and queen to C2 putting pressure on
the C6 Pawn so Rook the A6 best way to
play would just be Rook to B8 and go for
an active defense go against that B4
Pawn but Magnus played Rook to A6 and
here he overlooked a little uh something
uh even though it's not the best move
the best is just to play H4 open up the
the king said an attack but hookers
played Knight captures on E5 which is
also very nice uh probably Magnus missed
it because if everything gets traded off
captures captures and captures the rook
and A6 can now be picked off by the
queen just Queen to see for check wins
The Rook so Magnus instead after uh
Knight captures and E5 goes Rook A2 he
attacks Booker's Queen and this is where
the the magic happens the move from the
thumbnail uh is here even though Queen
to D3 is objectively best bookish gives
up the queen queen captures Rook Queen
captures Queen and not Knight captures
on D7 so a queen for rook and Knight but
also there are the two uh soon to be
connected fast Pawns in the middle of
the board now that's uh definitely
compensation uh Rook the d8 attacks the
Knight Magnus has to now figure out how
to set up some sort of a a defensive
perimeter here Knight to F6 check uh
King to F7 and of course Pawn to E5 and
this looks incredibly scary you have the
two connected pawns the bishop here
guards D5 Pawn there's The Rook there's
the knight uh if Magnus can if a googus
can somehow uh defend the E6 square like
if you could if you could get your
Knights to D4 guarding the E6 square and
you can play E6 check E7 uh then you're
probably just winning but Magnus will of
course try everything he can in order to
prevent this he plays Rook D2 attacks
The Rook here uh Queenie D2 attacks The
Rook F3 uh defending the rook and now
Queen captures on B4 we have Pawn to H3
uh creating some more breeding room for
the king also the king will be much
safer on H2 uh Rook to A8 now a Magnus
knows that he can't just uh wait and do
nothing he needs to uh put a rook and
Queen on the second Rank and create some
sort of a checkmating threat against
Google's King uh so Ponte D7 Lucas
advances his past d-pawn now Queen to D4
with check King H2 and now think the E6
then okay uh the queen rook and king are
doing a fine job locating the two pass
pawns uh Rook to C1 now going after the
C Pawn so C5 and now Knight the E4
again preparing the capture on C5 Magnus
advances it and now Knight the D6 again
going for the pawn hoping for King
captures on D7 uh and then Rook captures
on C4 but no Magnus further advances the
pawn pawn to C3 and now Knights the E4
and now you cannot Advance it further uh
you you have to give it up or you could
defend it with something like Rook to E3
uh but it would still be a much
different game the problem with Rook to
A3 is that you can still capture it's
not really a problem Knight captures on
C3 and you can't trade everything
because the queen has to keep guarding
the d8 square so here you would
basically just capture on D7 so however
you play it you are trading pawns so
instead knight uh the E4 King captures
on D7 was played Rook captures on C3 and
now King to d8 with Rook to C6 uh and
here Magnus played Queen to E3 and
interestingly here Magnus is completely
lost gookish can win a brilliant game
here if he finds the next move so feel
free to pause the video and win the game
for good cash while I give you a couple
of seconds
foreign
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on uh spotting the
the meeting web uh as the the pawn and
Bishop are a deadly combo and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is Pawn to E6 this is how you do it
now the problem is uh Bishop is coming
to D6 and then all of these squares will
be covered uh unfortunately gookers did
not play it uh uh uh if if he had you
know it would be game over for Magnus
point is that black has no counter play
whatever you play let's say play rookie
two something you're threatening Queen
captures on F3 then Queen captures and
G2 going for some sort of a Checkmate
look at this bishop C7 check and now if
you play King to C8 this is Checkmate
the Knight to D6 is Checkmate if you go
to E8 which is okay a little bit better
it's a light Square it doesn't matter
Bishop to D6 and now look at this bishop
Pawn combo completely locking in uh the
the black king Rook to see it is the
thread of Checkmate and even if you stop
this it doesn't matter Rook to C7 uh
whatever you play Rook to G7 7 is coming
so let's say G4 you don't care just Rook
the G7 now threatening this Checkmate
and if you play Pawn to G3 check okay
you can maybe do a few more checks when
you want checking H2 no more checks the
next move is Rook to G8 Checkmate so uh
that's that's the way it was however
after Queen to E3 gookish missed it he
played Queen to Rook to C3 attack
magnus's queen queen to D4 and now Rook
C2 trying to win the queen with Rook to
D2 so Magnus sidesteps with the King and
now Rook to D2 We have Queen to C4 and
Bishop to F2 So Okay Google still
playing a fine game but it's a shame he
he missed that we have Rook to A5 uh
putting pressure on the pawn here and
just Bush up to G3 and here Magnus
played Rook to A1 and uh he's incredibly
low on time he does have a one second
increment but it's 15 seconds for gokash
and only three seconds for Magnus four
and the rest of the game of course plus
increment and Google goes for it now
Ponte E6 he couldn't figure out what to
play here so he just pushed it uh hoping
that okay if if you capture maybe we can
play something like the D6 attack the
pawn maybe clean out the the king side
if King captures it's pretty much the
same but Magnum just played Queen to C1
he wants to Checkmate that white king so
of course uh Bishop to D6 would check
King capture Sun E6 and knocking the G3
but now Knight captures uh uh uh sorry
Pawn to H5 by Magnus and now Knight
captures on G5 with check with King to
F5 uh and now Rook the D5 with check
going for a king hunt here King to G6
and now uh Knight the E4 the game still
continues uh gookish is perfectly fine
here but he played Knight the E6 and he
completely uh threw the game away and
Magnus was incredibly composed here
incredibly calm because he played it
with one second on the clock and I mean
maybe okay two seconds or something like
that uh yeah he he he played Queen D1
check instantly and the gookash
immediately resigned here it connects
nicely with the Knight once the king
moves uh it doesn't really matter what
you do uh you're gonna lose the lose the
Knight and then the queen and Rook combo
is of course much much better than the
Rook Bishop combo uh so yeah tough break
for good cash he uh played a very nice
game I played a bold move sacrifice the
queen against Magnus Carlsen Magnus was
on the Run uh here it was uh I mean a
really a beautiful position
here when a queen captures the queen
captures was played uh gukesh was able
to set up this blockade he had the rook
and he won defended everything was nice
the bishop defended the Knight defended
the pawns defended it was merely a
matter of how to cross the E6 square
with the e-pawn about the Magnus
defended well Google couldn't do it and
in the end Magnus won so for those of
you who haven't seen my previous video
here's a little bit of uh extra info
those are the results of the fourth
round so gookers loses the Magnus in
Armageddon Anish loses to Hikaru in
Armageddon Tire loses to Wesley so in
Armageddon alireza loses the Fabiano
caruana In classical we've shown the
game it was a brilliant positional
Masterpiece by Fabi and the mommy darv
won a a brilliant attacking game against
here are the standings after round four
so far be in the lead in pretty much wow
what a lead almost uh almost uh well not
almost twice as as many points as Magnus
costs and that's that's I mean wow uh so
he got in second alireza in third then
we have a good cash Anish Wesley another
big Magnus Carlsen chakra and Aryan tari
still in last place and for those of you
who still haven't seen my previous video
These are the live ratings that were
updated after the the fourth round as
you can see Fabiano caruana is the new
world number two over to calireza over
took Nakamura overtook dingler and
overtook Ian if she he uh just shut up
for for places so absolutely incredible
and uh okay nothing really spectacular
happening in the in the top 20 aside
from that but there you have it I will
keep you updated after round five and so
on and so on uh so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it uh I really
enjoyed covering this a beautiful uh
attempt by
Gucci's ground I would like to thank
Mikhail Zakaria David gasparian Brandon
fukuda Nicholas Wolfe and Andres felonus
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
we'll see you soon continuing the
coverage of this wonderful event until
it finishes so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your Sunday